[Music]
[Applause]
here is Tom Brady after the game last
night saying goodbye to the media
I just want to say thank you guys for
everything this year I really appreciate
all your effort and I know it's hard for
you guys too it's hard for us players to
make it through and you guys got a tough
job and I appreciate all that you guys
do to cover us and everyone who watches
and a big fan of the sport we're very
grateful for everyone's support and um
you know hopefully um you know I love
this organization it's a great place to
be and thank you everybody for welcoming
me all you regulars and
um just very grateful for the respect
and and I hope I gave the same thing
back to you guys so thank you very much
appreciate it Greg Allman was there he
covers the Box the NFC South for Fox
Sports and he's kind enough to join us
after last night's festivities uh what
was Tom Brady saying there
it felt like a goodbye it felt like I he
hasn't done that in the last two seasons
it was nice for him to say it but yeah
thank you for welcoming me uh doesn't
sound like something you say to somebody
you expect to see an ota's or back in
July and August here so I don't know
that he's even decided yet um but that
that felt like I had some finality to it
seeing his parents on the field uh as he
walked off that felt like it might be an
ending but an ending to his Buccaneers
career or an ending to his NFL career
that's a good that's a good question and
I don't I mean he's he's that that's the
bigger question than it is for here in
Tampa absolutely I don't know
um he's got away his options here and he
kind of has to do that from a football
standpoint from a family standpoint it's
where Tom's been all season
um and I don't know if there's an
obvious answer that that satisfies both
for him uh enough to make him come back
at 46 and try it one more time with with
a third chapter somewhere
what did you expect last night
uh better than that
um you know I think there was some
momentum in the week just because the
Bucks had gotten a lot of guys back for
me injury
um
you know the opportunity that he had for
everything that this season wasn't they
always had the consolation of you know a
division championship a home playoff
game it's kind of like you get in the
tournament it doesn't matter what seed
you are anything's possible and they
always had that kind of hanging until
last night and then it looked like so
many games this year where they come out
uh flat on offense the defense kind of
gave way quickly and Brady's had these
games this year where there's you know
Brady magic and you go back to the Rams
and the Saints and the Cardinals and
even the Panthers and there's these
amazing finishes but it's games in which
they really didn't show up until about
five minutes were left and that's just
not a recipe for for winning against
good teams I had no problem picking
against the Buccaneers but I would never
pick against Tom Brady so it was a weird
dichotomy that I just you know the
Buccaneers weren't a good team this year
average margin of victory was two points
more than the Texans average margin of
Victory it was 6.3 Greg you're not yeah
and then Dallas does have Firepower
there the defense no showed you know
Brady throwing 64 times I mean that
that's a recipe for disaster
yeah and then the idea that they beat
Dallas in week one and won 19-3 was kind
of their best game probably where they
looked the most like they were supposed
to look if you will but it's so far
removed it's four months ago
um you know the fact that it was here
you'd think that's an advantage but they
haven't necessarily been a better team
at home
um so to have a zero in the fourth
quarter
um to have you know everything go the
way it did where the drama and the the
second half of Tom Brady's potential
last game is whether or not the opposing
kicker is going to make an extra point
but that's not what people saw going in
probably where's Bruce Arians in all of
this
uh I think just watching from afar I
think he's you know kind of laid low
this season um you'll see him at
practice he's in a golf cart just like
he was as a head coach
um but no I don't think it's anything
real prominent you know if Byron left
which goes I don't know if Bruce will be
back with this team even in the kind of
Consulting capacity he's been this year
they just put him in the Ring of Honor
it's probably a chance for him to just
go to retirement and enjoy himself
I know you covered the NFC South for Fox
Sports Carolina's got an opening uh what
role do you think Sean Payton plays in
Carolina if any
it's tough I mean I think he's probably
the the brass ring right now he's
probably the the top pick if you had all
these openings and who you'd like to
have I think they have enough draft
picks they could part with him he knows
the division well I think David Tepper
wants a splash higher probably they've
cast a wide net I think Steve Wilkes did
a good job there as an interim coach but
it seems like an ownership that wants to
to have a bigger hire I don't know if
that can be
um you know you heard harva early on
that's probably out of the way now uh
Peyton would probably be the best of
what's left but it also could be a young
offensive assistant they've certainly
started talking to a lot of those
I'll leave you with this any chance the
Buccaneers wouldn't want Tom Brady back
given this franchise again as ugly as
the season was it's the first time in
their history they've won back-to-back
division titles and in a division that's
still kind of lost like the NFC South is
uh if you had Tom Brady I think people
will think they're a favorite next year
regardless of what's around him so no I
think they'd love to have him back
um it's going to be a bit of a rebuild
and a different team whenever he's gone
so they want to keep that going as long
as they can Greg thank you we appreciate
it
thanks Dan Greg Allman covers the Bucks
NFC South for uh Fox Sports